often when I'm out in public a child
will stare me and if the child is
particularly brave they'll approach me
and ask are your pirate to which I then
need to respond once again yes I mean
let's be honest I've got two hooks
prosthetic legs and a punch on for hard
liquor all I need is an eye patch and a
parrot and I'm basically there but I
like being a pirate I find many
advantages to having a disability and
I'm not just talking about the money I
save on gloves or the fantastically
legitimate excuse for never having to
master chopsticks I'm talking about real
advantages I feel I've gained having
gone through physical adversity when I
was 19 I contracted a disease that
resulted in the loss of both my arms at
the elbows both my legs below the knee
and left enough scars on my face to
illicit Josie and Freddy Krueger now I
may never be able to communicate in sign
language but my increased resilience and
general ability to problem-solve has
been heightened by being forced to think
laterally to overcome problems that most
people aren't faced with one of the
first lessons that I learn immediately
followed the painful and arduous task of
learning how to walk again but at weight
went on to pay dividends for the rest of
my life was it happened when I attempted
to step up a curb now as rudimentary as
this action sounds to most of you
stepping up a curb is somewhat of a
challenge for those of us without ankle
movement so I tried stepping up the curb
the way I had always known how a front
on for days on end with no success until
it became obvious that the time and
effort I was investing into this
endeavor was clearly disproportionate to
the benefit of its outcome
so I decided to inspect the problem from
a different angle if I couldn't use an
ankle joint to achieve the range of
motion that I required to mount the curb
I would have to use a different joint
like my hip so I turn my body
perpendicular to the curb and place my
foot up sideways and I was able to step
up immediately within five minutes no
staircase was safe from my advances that
very day I climbed a staircase of three
flights which I was quite impressed with
as well except I realized I didn't know
how to get back down again I was a long
weekend now in my past life as an
able-bodied person I've been a guitarist
I was alright as a player but I'd never
really taken it further I never really
started a band or played live all that
much nonetheless music was a great
passion of mine and when I lost my arms
the idea that it may no longer be a part
of my life critically challenged my will
to keep living however the thought that
emerged immediately after being
discharged from hospital was if Ray
Charles can play the piano while blind
as a bat
let's get to work on a solution for this
guitar problem so consulting with an
engineer I designed a slide system that
would hook into my left hook and I
devised another pick holder system that
would clip into my right hook now if
this worked I would be able to play the
guitar
open chin on my lap like a slide so
after weeks of testing and alterations I
finally had the accessories back to play
the guitar again and I was right back
where I was before losing my hands being
issued with noise complaints from my
neighbors or is there but this time I
took it further I started a band with my
friends we wrote songs and recorded them
we even played gigs to real people not
as many as this
but even though is it just a tiny step
it was it it was a giant leap from what
I'd achieved when I was all in one piece
now while relearning every action that
one has ever cultivated cultivated might
seem like a significant undertaking and
believe me very much was in the short
term it was nonetheless having a
positive effect on the way that I
approached everything else in my life
not only did it transform my ability to
problem-solve but I also felt they
became more pragmatic less sensitive to
hindrances in some cases more patient
and magically transform people's
abilities to offer me their seats on
public transport trivial setbacks began
to pale in comparison to challenge as I
previously overcome and this allowed me
to take a calm and measured approach to
these challenges keeping them in
perspective and often even finding new
and improved ways to overcome them
the benefit of not dwelling on the
negative and just getting on with the
task at hand became self-evident it even
encouraged me to pursue some more
fulfilling career paths that may
otherwise have been inadvisable and who
would have thought that an appropriate
job for me might involve the meticulous
operation of electronic equipment to
curate dance music to people in
inaccessible places under the influence
of alcohol not I so in a competitive
industry where DJs have been
relentlessly honing their craft
desperate to attain gig sending demos to
clubs my best friend and I took a
different approach and we started our
own Club nine and we employed ourselves
as the DJs
suddenly we had a headline slot now when
we started that club night I could not
DJ the first time I ever got behind the
decks was on our opening night in front
of hundreds of people I'd only just
learnt where the play button was but
being previously faced with so many
ultimatums once forced to be astute in
adapting to new situations that club
night went on to become the
longest-running weekly Club night in
Sydney and where's DJ's went on to play
Australia's biggest music festivals so
eventually either learnt quickly or the
standards of clubbers have were gone
really down here coming close to death
can be an educational experience it's
certainly true that once priorities
receive somewhat of a realignment
immediately afterwards and it's also
true that some of those priorities are
met with an increased sense of urgency
but another more salient realization
that comes to life
if the triviality of our own
self-importance and self-consciousness
to truly understand the extent to which
your self-consciousness prohibits you
from engaging in opportunities should
lead everyone to take risks they
otherwise wouldn't we merely a blip on
the timeline of the universe right act
accordingly now the ideas that I'm
presenting today were imbued upon me
through some otherwise unfortunate
circumstances granted but they're lying
dormant in the lives of anyone who's
willing to exploit them if we all
understand that we all have unique
weaknesses and for honest about what
they are we can learn how to best take
advantage of them whether they be
mounting a curb or fear of presenting
sales reports or the inability to
sufficiently manage one's finances
looking at that guy
there lies the ability to learn to adapt
and even the ability to instinctually
rewire ones instinctual response to
challenges adversity is good and it has
the potential to make you stronger and
in the very least you can scare the hell
out of kids if you look like a pirate
thanks
[Applause]